[Müzik]
[Alkış]
çöp Kutusu
bunu patlatan butik kabiledeki işler
mobil karıştırma ancak altın erimemesi
fırınlar ve diğerleri tarafından birkaç
chili's show tırnak
sosyalizme ipad gerçek bir dolap
suç
Batı bu petrolde başka hiçbir [ __ ] yok
nasıl
sonra acele dünyadan geldi evet
patronun malzeme videosunu izleyin
Aşağıdaki kırmızı kalplere dikkat edin
chappie cdk çalışması yürüyüşe çık otur
renkli elbise kulübü benim gelmeli
iş belki biraz gittiğim yere gider
Bu Charlie'nin yaptığı bir şey olmalı korkuyorsun
benim kişisel karın olarak
çalışma rehberleri hepinize
çünkü adamlarımızı kesmemiz gerekiyor
trüf kesinlikle benim işimi de yaptın
bunu yap ben budamaya uydum
mevcut benlikten mm'ye de
spurlock play motel orada ol fred eğer istersen
iyi olan sende yok
bir zamanlar romano'nun hindistanı nasıl seyahat bahşişi ama eğer
düzeltme yolunda
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
o dolaşımdaki sen benim
[Müzik]
[Alkış]